eleven years after a jury found him not
guilty of the murders of Nicole Brown
Simpson and Ron Goldman O.J Simpson
wrote a book and he called it
I did it
here's the story behind this book
although acquitted on criminal charges
OJ was later found financially liable so
he has always owed money to the families
of the victims in 2006 to make some
money he decided to write if I did it
the premise of the book was literally
O.J saying I didn't do it but if I did
here's how and why I would have as you
can imagine the public was revolted by
that idea and all four hundred thousand
copies of the book that had been made
were destroyed but a year later a
bankruptcy court said hey look OJ still
owes these families money let's give
them this asset and so the Goldman
family took the book and published it
now they have always believed in OJ's
guilt and so they made the cover look
like this I did it but they're not
libeling him the title is still
technically if I did it
if I did it